this is a topic I've been meaning to
address for a long period of time but I
had an isolated incident happen to me on
Tick Tock that I think is very
emblematic of what's happening on social
media specifically within the healthcare
or medical community that I find to be
very very problematic and I want to say
on the outside of this video this is not
intended to attack anybody there's going
to be a reason why we cut out everyone's
names out of the video their usernames
because the purpose of this is to get
the medical community on the same page
to make sure that we improve our
communication style myself included and
learn from situations just like this one
in order to facilitate the message of
greater good or Public Health
a month ago I posted a short a cut down
of my interview with Sebastian
Maniscalco on the topic of RSV right now
with RSV one of the leading theories of
why there's such a run on hospitals is
because generally kids get RSV in their
first three years of life there's like a
50 chance each year that they get their
first episode and their first episode
with RSV is usually the worst the time
that where they need breathing
treatments maybe ICU stay and we've held
our kids back from school grandparents
and everybody that could have gotten
them sick for the last two years so now
the children that would have gotten it
each year have all gotten it at the same
time and it was their first time so it
kind of creates a run on hospitals
that's the leading theory RSV is a
respiratory virus that actually affects
people of all ages but it happens to be
worse in the very young and the elderly
what's been going on in our communities
is that we've seen higher rates of
hospitalization for children with RSV
over the last season which means
basically starting late October November
and we had some theories circulating as
to why that was going on I presented one
of the leading theories and I specify
one of the leading theories
very strongly here because I largely
believe as a physician myself who treats
children
that this is a multifactorial situation
meaning that there's probably multiple
factors and multiple theories that are
to be true and each of them have holes
because they do not on their own explain
the given spike in RSV hospitalizations
the theory of covid co-infection fluid
co-infection and immune dysregulation
partially true the fact that the timing
has been thrown off and our seasonal
patterns have been thrown off the fact
that pregnant patients weren't exposed
to RSV while pregnant therefore transfer
less protection for newborns partially
true the one that I presented spoke to
the fact that children over the last two
years or so had less exposure to RSV
because we were protecting them from
covid we were not having normal
activities normal interactions their
siblings were not going to school their
parents were not going to work and as a
result they had less exposure to RSV
when you have less exposure
um you're less likely to get RSV and
children who get RSV for the first time
usually get a worse case of RSV I wasn't
saying anything about children's immune
systems I wasn't saying anything about
our mitigation methods for covid I was
simply saying that because they had less
exposure to RSV that more children were
exposed to RSV this season as we're
going back to regular life and as a
result more of them were getting it for
the first time which means more severe
cases so it's basically just a timing
issue nothing to do with the strength or
or weakness of their immune systems in
fact this theory about the timing being
thrown off was not my theory it happens
to be one of the leading theories that
was spoken in news by New York
Presbyterian Hospital it was on ABC News
doctors on NPR talked about this Dr
mcgear from University of Toronto said
it perfectly in this interview there's
no question my mind that the biggest
impact of this this you know excess in
in illness in kids and in our icus is
related to the fact that kids just
weren't exposed to RSV
after posting this Tick Tock I got
comments from other doctors who were
debating uh the validity of this Theory
whether this is the theory that explains
the recent spike in RSV and some of
their arguments were right I actually
agreed with their arguments they were
saying that in Sweden they did not have
a strict of a lockdown and yet they're
still having this Spike why is that the
case and I'm not an expert on Sweden by
the way I I don't know exactly what
their Health Care system is like so I
don't even pretend to know that one of
the theories going around right now is
about covet immune system dysregulation
that some doctors believe that all these
children that have had covet in the past
have a weakened immune system therefore
as a result RSV affects them more there
may be some truth in this because any
co-infection whether we're talking about
covid flu rhinovirus these types of
co-infections can make your immune
system have fluctuations in its ability
to fight other viruses so that that's
partially true true there's some even
data showing that some immune cells are
impacted by having coveted in the past
the concept of immunity debt has popped
up among certain circles where they
believe
having children protected from exposure
has led them to have a weakened immune
system and this is not what I was saying
this is not how immune systems work yes
there is a hygiene theory that long-term
chronically over the course of Our Lives
if we hyper protect ourselves from
bacteria and constantly disinfect
everything it could have a meaningful
impact of our lives but over the course
of one or two years protecting children
from a serious situation like covet that
initially we knew very little about and
then we learned more and it was very
scary and our Hospital systems are
overwhelmed will not impact their immune
system so much so that they're weakened
that is not what I was saying and anyone
pushing that is inaccurate
to my disappointment this past week I
started seeing an increase of attacks
from other medical professionals on this
Tick Tock that I did not expect because
I totally see how we can debate what is
the reason for this RSV Spike but I
started seeing personal attacks in fact
there was one comment that upset me
because the person came in and said wow
you pretend to be a so-called doctor in
quotes here's an immunologist's
perspective
and it was like a personal attack on me
as if I'm not a real doctor treating
patients when I have RSV patients I have
coveted patients I give guidance I
strive to be the best doctor that I can
I've tried to be an accurate voice with
evidence-based medicine throughout the
pandemic
and to have this doctor do a personal
attack on me to upset me so I block them
in fact that was one of my New Year's
resolutions to try and not pay attention
to the negative comments as much that I
don't feel are reflective of who I am as
a person and block and move on but when
I blocked said person they created
content around the fact that I blocked
them as if I was silencing their medical
voice that I am a medical grifter that I
am the same as Dr Oz and fueling
misinformation which is so disheartening
because the whole reason this YouTube
channel exists is to put out
evidence-based medicine so to be accused
of spreading it myself
just just kills me because it doesn't
make a lot of sense to me why are people
doing this
some of the negative comments pointed
out that I was blocking and deleting
comments from people who disagreed with
this theory that I was presenting and
that's not the case I believe in healthy
discourse and debate we need more of it
it just needs to stay respectful because
the only reason I blocked the individual
I mentioned earlier was they started
personally attacking me in life if you
ever want to have a meaningful
conversation or even a debate with
someone you can't start it off by saying
so you're a so-called doctor or call
them a name and hope that they're going
to listen these same people who say
these things about me and attack me
also have been attacked themselves and
know what it feels like so we have to
approach this empathetically
we need to do a better job in social
media when it comes to healthcare
communication these are still sort of
hurdles that we need to get across as
communicators when it comes to a public
health setting and I think it's really
important that we move away from
toxicity within the medical community
because otherwise what happens is it
fractures our ability to educate people
we we fuel tribalism we we lead people
more confused and educated they feel
like this person knows the answer and
this person's evil this person's bad and
this type of dichotomy this black or
white thinking is unhealthy because
medicine is not a hundred percent
science there is an R to it there are
individual distinctions that need to be
made per patient that's why generalized
medicine is not the same as what is
accurate for the person sitting in front
of you so please doctors online I know
that we've been attacked throughout the
last few years for putting out accurate
information we
have seen arise a tremendous rise in
misinformation but do not lead this to
create displacement anger on other
Physicians or other individuals or even
your patients
who may say things that you disagree
with you may find slightly inaccurate
because the more we attack and the more
we label everything is misinformation
the more it takes away our ability to be
true fact Checkers and educators I'm
actually such a fan of healthy debate I
love it when people tell me that I'm
wrong and have a meaningful discussion
with me you've told me I've been wrong
several times and here's a full video
with all the mistakes that I've made in
my videos over the last few years I hope
you enjoy it and I hope as always you
stay happy and healthy